[Musica]
salve a tutti sono emilio bisignano e
sono uno studente quando mi è stato
chiesto di partecipare a the text la mia
reazione è stata ma in un posto dove
vanno a parlare i professionisti
professori start upper imprenditori di
successo e persone persone che vanno a
raccontare idee delle quali vale la pena
parlare ma io che c'entro
allora ci ho riflettuto e ho deciso di
parlarvi di qualcosa che è solo mio che
è la mia piccola esperienza non so
quanti di voi sa quanti di voi è
capitato di cercare magari su internet
qualcosa del tipo migliorate stesso
crescita personale oppure come
migliorare la gestione del proprio tempo
cosa del genere
a me è capitato soprattutto intorno ai
vent'anni e periodo
io penso di massima ricerca
dell'affermazione personale almeno per
quanto mi riguarda è quello che mi sono
trovato dinanzi è stato una è stata una
molteplicità di contenuti i più
disparati alcuni davvero tipo ricetta
magica
ricordo ancora con un po di paura e
terrore qualcosa che suonava del tipo
svegliati tutte le mattine alle 5
diventerai uno scienziato
inutile dirvi che non sono diventato uno
scienziato e che non ci ho neanche
provato altri invece altri contributi
erano organici fatti bene avevano delle
delle buone pratiche da seguire c'erano
dei modelli ai quali ispirarsi
devo dire davvero belli e positivi per
la mia formazione
in tutta questa varietà di modelli da
poter da poter seguire uno ricorreva
molto spesso ed era il
il modello del capitano d'azienda del
leader
se volete dirlo con uno spot
pubblicitario l'uomo che non deve
chiedere mai
quello al quale tutti si ispirano e tra
questi uno ricorreva con una certa con
una certa frequenza
steve jobs stay hungry stay foolish
siate affamati siate folli giusto per
giusto per capirci ebbene devo dire che
queste figure figure del carisma di
steve jobs hanno di certo ispirato la
mia formazione e penso che faccia bene
ad ognuno di noi indipendentemente da
quello che il nostro lavoro dal
venditore al professore allumina real
formatore al meccanico faccia bene ogni
tanto guardare a queste persone perché
hanno un grandissimo beneficio quello di
ampliare i nostri orizzonti di spostare
il nostro orizzonte un po più in là
perché troppe volte
guardiamo forse troppo vicini ai nostri
piedi il messaggio che io ho ricevuto
però purtroppo in quella fase della mia
vita è stato erroneamente chiaro il
messaggio che ho ricevuto è stato il
vincitore è solo il capitano d'azienda e
solo se noi ci pensiamo
chi ha creato iphone che ha ispirato
iphone
beh ce l'abbiamo davanti ci verrebbe da
dire steve jobs se noi chiedessimo a
google google ci direbbe che iphone è
stato ideato da più di trenta persone
quindi vede ne vedete solo alcune di
queste noi quante ne conosciamo
beh io sono un appassionato vi posso
dire che anche io conoscevo solo steve
jobs certo quello fondamentale
certo quello più importante ma di lui
conosciamo tanto gli altri non li
abbiamo neanche sentiti nominare ed è
stato con questo con questo modo di fare
con questo modo di pensare meglio
che io mi sono approcciato a costruire
la mia la mia vita le mie esperienze già
da quando avevo 18 anni ero membro
dell'associazione dei giovani soci del
credito cooperativo locale
un'associazione di giovani cooperatori
appunto e non mi sono fatto sfuggire
l'opportunità del rinnovo delle cariche
sociali ea 21 anni ne sono diventato
presidente
ebbene come mi sono approcciato a questa
nuova carica
beh mi sono approcciato con il metodo
erroneamente chiaro di cui vi dicevo
prima cercavo di essere probabilmente
non l'uomo solo al comando ma di certo
quello che in ogni modo doveva avere la
risposta giusta al momento giusto
cercavo di informarmi per poter avere
sempre la risposta ad ogni domanda è
sempre il consiglio giusto sempre la
supervisione e l'indirizzo giusto alle
cose
ebbene lasciate che vi dica mi dica una
cosa è essere e l'ho sperimentato sulla
mia pelle
steve jobs o tesla o einstein o leonardo
da vinci di certo non è impossibile
e però statisticamente è davvero molto
molto improbabile e allora siamo più o
meno sulla stessa barca non siamo
purtroppo o non siamo ancora uno di
questi geni e ed io ero sulla stessa
barca anche allora non ero il più bravo
ad avere le idee giuste al momento
giusto non ero il più bravo ad
organizzare non ero il più bravo a
rispettare le scadenze e neanche a
coinvolgere i soci ma sapete quando me
ne sono reso conto non quando la mia
mente mi diceva hai tu presuntuoso molto
irriverente la mia mente guarda che nel
fare questa attività
sembra che la persona che ti sta a
fianco sia molto più brava di te no non
allora perché la nostra mente si brava a
crearci queste voci ne che dovremmo
seguire ma è molto più brava nel farci
fa
nelle cose sempre allo stesso modo
quella che si chiama alla famosa zona
comfort ma se facciamo sempre così i
risultati sono tutto sommato abbastanza
decente quindi continuiamo in questo
modo
sapete invece quando me ne sono reso
conto quando mi sono trovato a farla
effettivamente insieme ad un altro
quella quella cosa è quella mansione e
quando mi sono reso conto in modo
plastico cioè proprio vedendolo che la
persona che mi stava a fianco non solo
non si sforzava quanto mi sforzavo io ma
raggiungeva risultati molto migliori e
con molto meno sforzo è stato allora
vedete che il fare insieme ma
chiamiamolo con il suo nome quella era
una associazione di giovani cooperatori
come vi dicevo il cooperare ha cambiato
effettivamente la mia prospettiva e
guardate a questo punto poi mi sono
chiesto ma che cos'ha di diverso il
cooperare da lavorare insieme perché io
avevo una serie di esperienze anche
lavorative d'estate nel pomeriggio
ebbene il lavorare insieme è
caratterizzato da una cosa se ci pensate
lo conosciamo tutti purtroppo o per
fortuna abbastanza bene il lavoro siamo
concentrati su quello che dobbiamo fare
su quello che dobbiamo creare e
progettare e vendere produrre e lo
possiamo fare anche con passione anzi è
bene fare il proprio lavoro con passione
una grande fortuna lo possiamo fare con
l'attenzione per gli altri
lo possiamo fare anche con una
particolare attenzione all'ambiente
anzi è ormai necessaria ma la nostra
direzione è chiara io devo raggiungere
quell'obiettivo raggiunto
quell'obiettivo il lavoro si intende
fatto il cooperare invece è diverso è
differente necessità si di un obiettivo
il fare senza un obiettivo sarebbe un
senso sarebbe probabilmente stupidità
mera azione fine a se stessa
il cooperare però presuppone un altro
elemento per caratterizzarsi che è il
come allora io cooperando come raggiungo
come devo raggio
in genere il mio obiettivo con il mio
sudore la mia passione il mio studio il
mio ufficio no non bastano
l'obiettivo nel cooperare si raggiunge
insieme o non si raggiunge e guardate ci
sono state tante tantissime tantissimi
episodi che ho vissuto e che mi hanno
fatto a poco a poco maturare questa
questo stato di coscienza attuale ve ne
voglio raccontare giusto uno per
chiarire meglio il concetto appena
finita la mia esperienza da presidente
continua a dare una mano mi ero
appassionato e sono tuttora un un
giovane socio attivo e continua a dare
una mano e subito mi resi conto che è sì
io ero più bravo o magari a sbrigare
quelle cose tipo autorizzazioni perché
ci avevo ormai una certa manualità dopo
degli anni ad averlo fatto
il nuovo presidente però era molto più
bravo nel coinvolgere le persone è una
ragazza che ci dava una mano e ci dà una
mano ha fatto una locandina che era
bellissima
ecco anche in quella situazione io mi
sono reso conto che cooperare ha
cambiato la mia prospettiva e guardate
con questa nuova prospettiva noi abbiamo
raggiunto dei forze piccoli ma per noi
molto grandi risultati
tanti eventi sul territorio
siamo stati spesso annoverati e siamo
ancora annoverati tra le migliori
pratiche a livello nazionale e il nostro
modello viene proposto alle associazioni
di giovani soci che nascono siamo
riusciti a portare qui a cosenza il nono
forum dei giovani soci del credito
cooperativo che si svolgerà proprio in
questi giorni nella nostra città
e sapete anche io dal punto di vista
personale con questo nuovo modo di fare
non ho avuto una mar una mortificazione
assolutamente ho potuto fare il
portavoce nazionale dei giovani soci
quindi il rappresentante nazionale mi è
stata data l'opportunità di scrivere e
pubblicare un manuale di
alfabetizzazione bancaria cooperativa e
oggi sono qui a parlare ad un telex
cosa che a me fa vi devo confessare
particolarmente piacere e onore
vedete probabilmente io potrei già unire
qualche puntino e e andando avanti
chissà quanti ne potrò unire ancora e
vedete dall'unione di questi puntini
potrebbe uscire il disegno che è la mia
vita è se lo fate voi uscirà un disegno
che è la vostra vita e allora io ne sono
sicuro io credo che il cooperare il fare
insieme con gli altri abbia migliorato e
non di poco il tratto della penna penso
anche che migliorare se stessi debba
essere una priorità per tutti per
chiunque qualunque sia la nostra
il nostro impegno e penso che noi
abbiamo il dovere di condividere le
nostre conoscenze e di appropriarci in
modo benevolo delle conoscenze che gli
altri mettono a disposizione e guardate
ci sono una miriade di opportunità per
farlo insieme ci sono tante associazioni
tante cooperative che trattano degli
argomenti più disparati
ecco vi invito trovate cercate quella
che tratta l'argomento che più vi
appassiona e lasciatevi travolgere e se
non la trovate fondate né voi una date
tanto
ammettete i vostri limiti e fatene una
ricchezza per gli altri e verrete
ripagati cento volte tanto e senza
rendervene conto avrete ben messo a
fuoco il vostro futuro
vi ringrazio
[Applauso]